corona seit einem jahr hat uns das virus
fest im griff woher das virus kommt das
war bisher nicht ganz klar
von fledermäusen sagt die whu jetzt hat
ein hamburger professor hunderte
hinweise zusammengetragen und er ist
sich sicher das virus stammt aus einem
labor in haan es wurde also künstlich
erzeugt professor roland wiesendamm
erklärt uns hier gleich live in dieser
sendung seine schwerwiegenden indizien
[Musik]
corona kam doch aus einem labor in wuhu
hahn zu diesem schluss kommt jetzt der
hamburger professor roland wiese
er hat dafür hunderte hinweise
zusammengetragen und analysiert
ein labor unfall könnte also der
ursprung für die weltweite pandemie
seien
wir sprechen jetzt mit profil professor
roland wiesen daher ist uns jetzt
zugeschaltet herzlichen guten abend ja
welche hinweise haben sie
zusammengetragen und analysiert es sie
jetzt zu diesem schluss kommen ja zum
einen haben diese coronaviren die
derzeitige pandemie auslösen spezielle
eigenschaften sie können besonders
leicht und menschliche zellen andocken
und dann in diese einbringen so dass
eben eine sehr leicht übertragen von
mensch zu mensch zustande kommen kann
und dass es tatsächlich eine eigenschaft
die bisherige coronaviren so eben nicht
hatten
das heißt corona wir haben ja bereits
schon frühere pannen termin oder
epidemien ausgelöst wie saas und mehr
aber in keinem der fälle ist es zu einer
weltweiten pandemie gekommen das sind
tatsächlich neue eigenschaften die wir
so bislang alkohol affären ich gekannt
haben und das interessante ist nun dass
es eben wissenschaftliche
veröffentlichung gab in der
fachliteratur
wo eben beschrieben es wie eine
forschergruppe des instituts für
virologie genauso ihre experimente
durchgeführt haben um coronaviren für
menschen ansteckend gefährlicher und
leider wir sehen müssen auch tödlicher
zu machen
diese sogenannte gaynor function
forschung steht bereits seit zehn jahren
in der kritik auf internationaler ebene
von seiten sehr viele wissenschaftler
aber auch der politiker es hat ein
verbot solcher forschung gegeben zu
zeiten der barack obama regierung in usa
zwischen 2014 und 17
es ist thematisiert worden vom deutschen
bundestag und dem deutschen ethikrat
bereits 2014
aber offensichtlich hat sich niemand
mehr daran erinnert dass tatsächlich
viele wissenschaftler vor so einer
weltweiten
aufgrund dies auch hoch risikoreichen
forschung mit viren zu stande kommt die
eben nicht mehr dann kontrollierbar sind
insbesondere weil bekanntes das immer
wieder labor unfälle passieren und man
muss in dem zusammenhang vor allen
dingen betonen dass wissenschaftler
bereits 2012 die gefahr einer weltweiten
pandemie in den kommenden zehn jahren
das heißt bis 2022 zu 80% abgeschätzt
haben auf basis dieser gefährlichen
gegner function forschung und wir müssen
unbedingt verhindern dass es zu weiteren
pandemien in der zukunft kommt das heißt
jeder wissenschaftler ist eigentlich
aufgefordert sein wissen und seine
möglichkeiten beizutragen dass dieses
thema jetzt wirklich von allen seiten
ernst genommen wird und letzten endes
auch ein öffentlicher druck zustande
kommt es besteht eine totale des geplant
zwischen der öffentlichen reaktion und
auf der politischen reaktion nach dem
ereignis in fukushima
das war ein schreckliches unglück aber
es war letzten endes eine lokale folgen
letzten endes ist zunahme ist damals
aber was wird derzeit erleben ist eine
weltweite pandemie die aufzeigt welches
gefahrenpotenzial mit biologischen
erregern letzten endes zustande kommen
können bisher gab es ja immer liegt der
ursprung kam von fledermäusen baum
halten sie das für unwahrscheinlich
ja das ist ja nicht falsch also diese
erreger kommen natürlich ursprünglich
von fledermäusen das ist ja gar nicht
falsch und es steht auch nicht im
widerspruch zu dem was mitglieder der
untersuchungskommission gesagt haben nur
ist es eben so dass gerade an diesem
hang institut eben die weltweit größte
sammlung von diesen fledermaus viren
existierten und die stammen aus sehr
weit entfernten höhlen etwa 2.000 km
entfernt im südchinesischen provinzen
und es ist extrem unwahrscheinlich dass
ich so die fledermaus letzten endes auf
so einen weg begeben hat von 2000
kilometern und dann just in der
zehn-millionen-metropole vivo hahn
direkt in der nähe eines solchen
instituts eine weltweite pandemie
ausgelöst hat die wahrscheinlichkeit
dafür ist verschwindend gering und dazu
ist zu sagen dass auf der basis der in
dezent ich in meiner studie
zusammengetragen habe auch unabhängig
amerikanische kollegen auch mit
zusätzlichen indizien die
wahrscheinlichkeiten abgeschätzt haben
für einen laborunfall und für eine
natürliche übertragung über ein zwischen
wirtstier als eine zoonose und das
ergebnis dieser wissenschaftlichen
analyse einer wissenschaftlichen
abschätzungen der wahrscheinlichkeiten
war dass es eben zu 99,8 ein labor
unfall war und nur zu 0,2 prozent
wahrscheinlichkeit eine zoonose das
heißt alle natürlich übertragung von
corona während von fledermäusen auf den
menschen in ihren augen wurden denn
beweise oder zumindest hinweise
unterdrückt die belegen würden dass
corona tatsächlich im labor entstanden
ist nun strikte beweise gibt es bis
heute nicht das würde ja bedeuten für
die laborunfall hypothese dass man
letzten endes eine mitarbeiterin oder
ein mitarbeiter des humaninstituts dazu
bringen könnte eine entsprechende
zeugenaussage zu machen
im umgekehrten fall einer zu lose müsste
eindeutiger inzwischen wird hier ähnlich
wie früher bei saas und mehr
identifiziert werden
und auch der übertragungsweg im
eindeutig identifiziert werden von
fledermäusen über dieses zwischen wird
dir zum menschen
beide stritten beweise sind bislang
ausstehend tatsache ist aber dass eben
die zahl und eben auch die qualität der
indizien derzeit ganz ganz klar geben
für einen laborunfall sprechen und es
ist extrem wichtig dass das eben auch
auf breiter ebene wagen
wird weil auch für die politischen
entscheidungsträger ist es extrem
wichtig nun zu wissen war es nun einen
laborunfall bruder war es eine
natürliche zu lose weil die konsequenzen
und letzten endes auch die
entscheidungen die getroffen werden
müssten wären ja in beiden fällen
vollkommen verschieden
eine letzte frage sie sind eigentlich
nahm um wissenschaftler warum haben sie
sich jetzt mit dem corona virus und vor
allem mit der art wie es ausgebrochen
ist beschäftigt ich habe mich damit
bereits zu beginn des jahres 2020 des
letzten jahres beschäftigt ich bin
wissenschaftler geworden weil ich extrem
neugierig bin und die dinge letzten
endes ergründen möchte die vorgänge in
der natur und es gibt natürlich seit
über einem jahr nichts wichtigeres als
die frage des ursprungs dieser pandemie
wir können uns natürlich derzeit
unterhalten welche lockerungsmaßnahmen
drei wochen früher oder später jetzt
eingeleitet werden soll
das ist aber nicht existenziell
entscheidend existenziell entscheidend
für die zukunft unserer kinder und
kindeskinder ist aber nun ob sich solche
pandemien in regelmäßigen abständen
wiederholen weil die gefahr eben nicht
gebannt es sondern es gibt diese art
hoch risikoreiche forschung nach wie vor
und man kann letzten endes immer noch
den standpunkt vertreten dass es nicht
so lohse war
tatsache ist aber dass diese hoch
risikoreiche gehen auf function
forschung überhaupt nichts dazu
beigetragen hat besser vorbereitet zu
sein auf diese weltweite pandemie die
nun mal realität geworden ist das heißt
wir müssen darauf hinwirken dass diese
art von forschung weltweit gebannt wird
so wie es die amerikanische regierung
bereits in den jahren 2014 bis 2017
getan hat vielen dank professor riesen
danke dass ihr uns heute abend ihre
einschätzung noch mal genauer erklärt
haben dass corona eben doch ein labor
unfall waren dann kann einen schönen
abend an sie